[Müzik]
Merhabalar
hazine denen şeyin iki koşulu olduğunu
düşünüyorum
birincisi göz önünde olmak İkincisi de
kimsenin bunun farkında olmaması Ben
bugün size 2 hazine ile geldim birincisi
hali hayatımı kazandığım yaratıcılık
mevzusu İkincisi de bunu Aslında
balıklardan
öğrenebileceğiniz gerçeği
balıklarla iletişim konusunda Tedirgin
olabileceğinizi biliyorum ama çok fazla
bir şeye gerek yok
Sadece açınızı biraz değiştirerek
bakmanız yeterli hadi başlayalım
Bu gördüğünüz harika canlı bir deniz otu
salonda hiç kimsenin neresi harika diye
düşündüğünü sanmıyorum çünkü gördüğünüz
gibi neredeyse fosforik renkleri tülden
bir bedeni Muhtemelen de dans eder gibi
hareketleriyle neredeyse yaşayan her
canlıya çok estetik gelebilecek bir form
Deniz otu oregon ve Japon Denizi
Sahillerinde Hatta derinliklerinde demek
daha doğru olur 400 metre derinlikte
yaşıyor bu derinlikte güneş ışığı yok
güneş ışığı olmadığı için Deniz Otu kör
o kör olduğu gibi çevresindeki arkadaşı
eşi dostu akrabaları da gör Dolayısıyla
400 metre derinlikte kimse onu görmüyor
o da kimseyi görmüyor Peki neden bu
kadar harika
benim Bununla ilgili bir tezim var
Muhtemelen Sadece kendisi için yani en
görünmez anlarınızda kendinize en
görünmez hissettiğiniz anlarda bile
Muhtemelen size özel özgün ve güzel dur
diyor sanıyorum böyle bir mesajı var
Deniz Otu tavrına kadınların neredeyse
tamamında rastlamak mümkün onların
içlerinde küçük bir deniz otu var
kadınlar mesela hiç kimsenin görmeyeceği
Hatta günlük yaşamlarında kendilerinin
bile hiç görmedikleri iç giyimlerine çok
özen gösteriyorlar sadece kendileri için
erkeklerde buna rastlamak zor ama
imkansız değil Mesela bu Deniz otunun
altındaki Bu harika özdeyiş bir erkeğin
Kendimden Başka umudum yok 400 metre
derinlikte Karanlıkta Yaşayan bir
canlıya çok yakışıyor değil mi Kendimden
Başka umudum yok
terentüus da bir tür deniz otu terentius
milattan önce 190'lı yıllarda Roma'da
bir köle olarak doğuyor
köle olmakla ilgili sinema ve edebiyatla
ilgili birikimlerinizden belki empati
yapabilirsiniz ama köle doğmakla ilgili
Empati yapmak zor neredeyse 400 metre
derinlikte sizi kimsenin görmediği
Kimsenin de sizi görmediği Kimsenin de
sizi görmediği sizin de kimseyi
görmediğiniz bir Karanlığa doğmak gibi
bir şey
terantiyus ama Deniz Otu gibi Öz saygısı
olan bir erkek 15 yaşına gelmeden
kendisini bulduğu her fırsatta eğitmeye
çalışıyor bilim Nezaket iletişim servis
kısa süre sonra sahibi Senatör
lütfiano'nun dikkatini çekiyor Ve ona
özgür insan gibi eğitim alma hakkı
tanıyor hemen ardından Azad ediyor Yani
özgürlüğünü veriyor hemen ardından
terentius filozoflar konseyine kabul
ediliyor
köle olarak da olan bir yaşamdan
filozoflar konseyine
terentius 35 yıllık toplam yarısı
karanlık hayatında 6 Eser veriyor
bu 6 eserin Hepsi de komedi
Şimdi burada Belek'te
Sahilde Bir otelde bir otelin loş bir
salonunda
terentius ve Deniz Otu sizlere ekrandan
parlıyor
Muhtemelen Deniz Otu bize bir şeyler
anlatmak istiyor
ikinci balığımız bir köpek balığı onu
biz En çok bu imajıyla tanıyoruz Hatta
neredeyse Bu imajıyla tanıyoruz
bizim dünyamıza çıkardığı yüzgeciyle
tahmin edersiniz yaratıcı bir yaşamın Ve
tatmin dolu bir yaşamın
bir koşulu var size çizilen sınırlardan
çizgilerden size biçilen dünyada bir
yerinizi her zaman dışarı çıkarmak yani
o dünya ile yetinmemek
gerek mesleki olarak gerek kişi olarak
makam olarak şu olarak bu olarak
hepimize bir dünya çiziliyor hepimizin
belli sınırları var ama bir tarafımızı
aynı köpek balığı gibi o sınırlardan
dışarı çıkmak çıkarmak zorundayız bunu
çıkarmazsak solarız mesela markalar
köpek balığının bu dersinin farkında
kadın kozmetik markaları kadın
özgürlüğüne
spor markaları
ırkçılığa holdingler
düşünce özgürlüğüne durmadan Yüzgeç
çıkarıyor Hatta hatırlarsınız bir dönem
bütün marka iletişimini bir kovboyun
üzerinden yapan markalar vardı
Sen tütün üretiyorsun abi ne alaka valla
Bazı lastik otomobil lastiği markaları
aileleri kavuşturduğunu iddia ediyordu
öğrenci iseniz iş yaşamına memursanız
zanaate ya da e-ticarete iş adamıysanız
antika'ya daha daha yüksek sanatlara
resme müziğe Yüzgeç çıkarabilirsin
emin olun ait olduğunuz evrenin dışında
kendinizi var Ettiğiniz her evrende daha
Saygın karşılanırsınız
balıklar Evrim de geçirse ve yüz sene
kalsa su altında köpek balığının filmini
yapmazlar bu Yüzgeç
kendi dünyasının dışında bizim
dünyamızda inanın çok daha karizmatik
Muhtemelen köpek balığı da bize bir şey
anlatıyor
leziz mor küçük büyüktür
Çağdaş dünyanın tasarım trendlerinden
minimalizme en kısa ve en havalı anlatan
slogan bu
günlük yaşamımızda Biz tasarımcılar
Mimarlar vesaire bunu çok kullanıyoruz
ama Hiçbirimiz hamsi kadar hayatımıza
geçiremeyiz
zamanında bu balığa iyi baksaydık bu laf
havalı bir laz atasözü olabilirdi
mesela; ama fırsat kaçırdık hamsi
malumunuz küçüklüğün metaforu hamsi
kadar Beynim var deriz hamsi kadar
adamsın hamsi kadar akıllı yok sende
Üstelik horlanan bir küçüklük metaforu
ama biliyor musunuz hamsi dünyada
vadetliğinin tam karşılığını veren tek
balıktır
2 kilo hamsi 2 kilo yemek demektir
2 kilo lüfer 2 kilo fener balığı 2 kilo
levrek 2 kilo yemek değildir
Kafalar yüzgeçler kuyruklar kılçıklar
gider o anlı şanlı balıklar masanıza
anca 1 kilo gelir
sizi terazide yalan söylemez hamsinin
gündelik yaşamı tersine çeviren bir
özelliği daha var Karadenizliler varsa
bilirler kışın Karadeniz'de havalar
soğuduğunda Yani fakir fukara için yaşam
gittikçe zorlaştığında hamsi çok ucuzlar
Ama öyle böyle değil çok fazla ucuzlar
yıl boyu balığın Yanından bile geçemeyen
dar gelirliyim insanlar günlerce
evlerine kilolarca balık götürebilirler
Doğanın insan için şartları çok
zorlaştırdığı bir dönemde
hamsi bunun köleleri etmek için
kendinden insanlara bir ziyafet yaratır
hayatta böyledir Bazen küçük sandığımız
şeyler görkemli derecede büyük büyük
sandığımız şeyler de acınası derecede
küçüktür büyük fikirler sizi zengin
yapabilir meşhur da yapabilir ama küçük
fikirler küçük duyarlılıklar sizi
yaratıcı yapar
Hani veri çağındayız ya veri veri veri
veri data bu çağdayız Alın size bizden
yüzyıllar öncesinden beri veri çağında
yaşayan bir canlı bu kadarını gösterince
bile hepiniz anlayabiliyorsunuz ne
olduğunu her tarafı veriden ibaret
hayvan bütün vücuduyla hissediyor
dokunuyor hissediyor kaydediyor
mesajı da çok açık bize ne söylüyor
olabilir ki evinde işinde sosyal
yaşamında her yerde temalara insanlara
dokun diyordur
kollarınızda vantuzlar olmayabilir
zihninizde vantuzlar olsun köpek
balığının ahtapotun dersini alın
[Müzik]
müstah deme
Bakkal çırağının adını öğrenin çocukları
dinleyin kendinizi çalışanınızın
öğrencinizin ortağınızın müdürünüzün
aslınızın üstünüzün yerine koyun
ahtapotun dersini alın bundan bir hafta
kadar önce
17 yaşında bir kızım var birlikte
starbucks'a gittik gece yarısı havalı
biçimde tek eve kahve alacağız
her tarafta tanıtım afişleri balkabaklı
Latte portakallı kahve cevizli Bilmem
cheesecake orada Türk çayı yazıyor Türk
çayı ne ya onu bari bize bırak Sen Çölde
dükkan açsan doluyor niye çay yapıyorsun
o akıllı bir ahtapot ona da dokunacak
netflix bu konuda çıtayı zirveye koyuyor
rekabete Dokunma konusunda CEO'su şöyle
diyor mesela tekrar rakibimiz uyku
başka bir ilham balığı Yunuslar
yunusları normal yaşamda görmenizin bir
yolu var sizle yarışırken görebilirsiniz
öbür türlü parklar vesaire dışında
Yunuslar görmeniz zor Çünkü onlar
denizlerde rastladıkları yabancı bütün
araç ve canlılarla yarışırlar neden
hayatlarının devamlılığı süratlerinin
devamlılığına bağlıdır bizim hayatımızın
devamlılığı neye bağlı zihinsel
kapasitemizin ve
problem çözme yeteneğimizin
devamlılığına bağlı O yüzden Onlar bizi
her gördüklerinde Aslında Bize şu dersi
veriyor olabilirler kendi idmanını yarat
yani
kendinle yüzleşebileceğin sorular sor ve
tamamını çöz Ben fazla vaktinizi almamak
için iki soru getirdim böyle çok soru
uydurup Akşamları boş vakitlerinizde
çözebilirsiniz birincisi Orta Çağda
Mesleğiniz ne olurdu ikincisi Siz bir
ülke olsanız bayrağınız nasıl olur
bunları öyle basit sorular değil Orta
Çağda Mesleğinizi bulmak için mesela
birçok soruyu cevaplamanız lazım aslında
sizden sertifikalarınızı diplomalarınızı
yönetim kurulu üyeliklerinizi
workshoplarınızı katıldığınız eğitimleri
onları alsak
Sizden ne olur Çünkü Orta Çağda kimse
bunlara bakmayacak
hür bir insan saf bir kişilik olarak siz
ben hepimiz ne işe yararız bizden
Nalbant mı olur Nakkaş mı tiyatrocu mu
Hokkabaz mı
her şeyinizi sizden alsak Sizden ne olur
Mesela iyi bir soru En azından size bir
gece geçirtebilir İkincisi de en az o
kadar derin ülke olsanız bayrağınız
nasıl olurdu hepimiz değerlerimiz var
benim değerlerim değerleri değerlerim
diye geziyoruz değerlerimizi bir
saymıyoruzdur bile son Sayan 6-8 ay
öncedir Hatta yaşlandıkça Ulan bu
değerler vardı benim onlara bir bakalım
falan filan da demiyoruz Bir
üzerlerinden de geçmiyoruz ama hadi
kendi bayrağını tasarla dediğimde
Elinizde bir değerleriniz var önünüzde
bir dikdörtgen
değerlerinizi o dikdörtgenin nasıl
koyarsınız hepsini de koyamazsınız asker
mektubu gibi olur bayrak da bayrak gibi
olmalı yani
bir düşman ancak bu kadar güzel
görünebilir
şöyle açılayım görme fırsatınız olsun
gündelik yaşamımızda da genelde güzel
görünen Düşmanlar var Onların düşman
olduğunu anlayana kadar yeniliyoruz yani
tehlikeli tarafları Bu kaplan balığının
Muhtemelen bize mesajı da bu güzel
düşmanlara diyor dikkat et
kaplan balığı o kadar lanet bir balık ki
bulunduğu ortamda kendi dışındaki bütün
türleri yok ediyor Hatta Şu son dönemde
denizlerimizde de bütün habitatı
mahvediyor
çağımızda var mı böyle Düşmanlar güzel
çekici Görünen bir bakalım isterseniz
buyursunlar sol taraftaki benim
gençliğimde maruz kaldığım ekran sağ
taraftaki de kızımın gençliği boyunca
maruz kaldığı ve daha kalmaya devam
edeceği ekran benim gençliğimdeki bir
ekrana karşılık kızımın gençliğindeki 5
ekran biraz da tehditkar duruyor Bu
ekranlarla hayatımıza giren başka Kaplan
balıkları var aynı Kaplan balıkları gibi
renkliler cıvıl cıvıllar ve iletişim
dünyamıza girdikçe onlar da sözlerimizi
yok ediyorlar kelimelerimizi
duygularımızı yok ediyorlar onlarla
iletişmeye başladıkça Nereye ne
yazacağımızı şaşırıyoruz
çok taze bir örnek Gerçi memlekette taze
facia örneği bitmiyor yani bundan tazesi
de var kusura bakmayın sunumda bu kaldı
Bartın'daki maden kazasında faciasında
diyelim
İnstagramda yayınlanmış gerçekten 3 tane
posttu
bu sunumdaki her şey gerçektir hiçbir
kömür ısıtamaz babası madende ölmüş
çocuğun yüreğini yazmış Adam duygusal
zekası yüksek bir resim koymuş ve
paylaşmış bu bana dokunuyor Üstelik
madende Tamam işçiler öldü ama çocukları
Eyvah çocukları diyorum içimde bir
dikkat etmediğim bir duyguyu da
uyandırıyor gayet iyi bir içerik ikinci
abimiz o kadar duygusal başarılı
yetenekli değilmiş Geçmiş olsun Bartın
yazmış Ne yapsın gündemle ilgili ocağın
Belki de bir fotoğrafını koymuş ama
üçüncü adam Afedersiniz
üçüncü adam mevzunun hiç farkında değil
Hashtag Bartın yazmış ve üzgün bir sarı
patates
Muhtemelen bu faciayla duyduğu acıyı
bize bu sarı patatesle anlatacağını
düşünüyor
ama anlatmıyor
Eğer dikkatli bakarsanız balıklar
kibrit düşünceden çoklu fonksiyonelliğin
faydalarına kadınların toplumdaki
öneminden dünyadaki siyasi kutuplara
sizlere Acayip şeyler anlatabilir Mesela
denizcilerin en sevdiği balık deniz
kızları
yıllar öncesinden bize hibrit düşün
hibrit düşün diye bas bas
bağırıyorlarmış Biz o Çağa yeni
geldiğimizi sanıyoruz Üstelik o hibrit
kafayla düşünülen her şeyde tarihte
efsane olmuş üzerinden geçememişiz bir
türlü Hatta bugün düşünülen bile efsane
olmuş Yeter ki ibret düşün buraya
koymadığım bir tane daha diye var bu
çağın adı ileride Onunla anılacak neden
koymadım Çünkü hepinizin cebinde bir
tane var
cep telefonları
hibrit bir mucize çünkü ama bize
fısıldamış deniz kızları
Testere balıkları çekiç kafalı köpek
balıkları hepsi yardım etmiş ama biz
şaha yeni girmişiz sonra kadınların
hayatımızdaki benzersiz zenginliği
Onunla da ilgili bir balık var
Kadınlar her soruna onu çok
berraklaştırarak liflerine ayırarak
yaklaşırlar
onların kumandalarında Biz erkeklerinki
gibi iki düğme yok bizde aç kapa
kadınların kumandalarında yüzlerce düğme
var Herhangi problem bir problemle
ilgili etrafınızda tanışacak Bir uzman
Bulamazsanız bir kadına danışabilirsiniz
herhangi bir kadına çözümle ilgili size
bir nokta atışı yapamayabilir ama
anladığınız sandığınız sorunu Aslında
anlamadığınızı anlarsınız
önünüzde o kadar berrak bir açılım
yaratır ki
bir türlü sorunu çözersiniz Onlar bizden
daha olgun daha erken olgunlaştıkları
için ayrıca Hayata da bu anlamda daha
sahip çıkıyorlar
bu benekli Akdeniz horozu Bu mevzuya
yüzlerce yıl önce uyanmış benetle
Akdeniz o pozları hayatlarının
olgunlaşıncaya kadar ki dönemlerini dişi
olarak yaşarlar
olgunlaştıktan sonra gerisini erkek
olarak idare ederler
[Alkış]
düşünsene Bir denizde dünyaya
geliyorsunuz en hassas kararları
vermeniz dönemler yani ahtapot
görüyorsunuz köpek balığı bilmem ne
falan çok ciddi kararlar vermeniz lazım
olgunlaşana kadar bu kararların hepsini
bir dişi olarak alıyorlar gerisini
deneyim tecrübe erkek olarak idare
ediyorlar
dünya siyasetiyle de ilgili balıklar var
mesela malumunuz Fransız ihtilalinden
beri dünya sağ ve sol iki kutup'a
bölünmüş biraz çabalasam bulurdum ama
sunuma yetiştiremedim solcu bir balık
bulamadım ama size sağın Kalesi bir
balık getirdim yaldızlı pisi balığı
yıldızlı pisi balığı yaldızlı
iki gözü de sağda
diğer tarafla hiç ilgilenmiyor
bu muhafazakar değişime direnen balığın
harika bir özelliği var Ama bulunduğu
Her ortama göre renk değiştiriyor
bir balık size bir şeyler anlatmak için
daha fazla ne yapsın şimdi
İsterseniz
yüzgecinizi size ait O dünyadan yukarı
çıkarmak isteyin isterseniz
karanlıklarda Deniz Otu gibi parlamak
isteyin isterseniz yunus balıkları gibi
her gün kendinizle yüzleşmek isteyin
Sonuçta bir şeye ihtiyacınız var
cesarete
cesaretin de balığı var Küçük Kara Balık
Küçük Kara Balık Hali hazırda denizlerde
yaşamıyor ama ne dedi demin Picasso
hayal ettiğiniz her şey gerçektir
Dolayısıyla Küçük Kara Balıkta gerçek
gözünden kaçıranlar rastlamayanlar için
bir özet geçeyim Küçük Kara Balık İranlı
yazar Samet Behrengi'nin efsane çocuk
hikayesi
hikayenin Hatta Küçük Kara Balık
hikayede Küçük Kara balığımız küçük bir
Dere yatağında yaşıyor ve dünyanın
oradan ibaret olduğuna asla inanmıyor
mutlaka bir de bu dere diyor bir yerlere
atıyordur daha büyük Göllere denizlere
bir yerlere oralara ulaşmalıyım herkes
onu ikna etmeye çalışıyor Ama
başaramıyorlar küçük kara balık büyük
tehlikeler riskler alıp sonunda Büyük
Okyanusa ulaşıyor Samet behrengi'ye
Muhtemelen İran gizli servisi öldürüyor
ama Küçük Kara Balık ve onun harika
Cesur mesajı bize yıllardır ulaşmaya
devam ediyor Benim Sizlere anlatmak için
avladığım balıklar bu kadar
yeni renkli şeyler öğrenmek için
Sizler de kendi Balıklarınızı
avlayabilirsiniz Hadi rastgele
[Müzik]